this idea was some people are better
than others
and that wasn't you know power evenly
distributed like a democracy yeah i mean
it's true
people some people are better than
others that's the right that that means
you're right
you're a conservative yeah not a
conservative right you're right-wing
yeah so
you know michael malus obviously yeah
yeah so he so he asked me he's like
the new right how do you define what
left and right is and he asked do you
think some people are better than others
yeah and i was like yes and he goes okay
i think some people are doing better
than other people but i don't think that
they're just better like if someone was
born into my situation they'd be
literate
you're over you're way overthinking it
so he said the left gives you a speech
the right would say yes i'm obviously on
the left because well but
but i said but the the saying yes is the
correct answer
some people are really tall and they can
play basketball really well
and so what what we mean by better
doesn't
if we're just speaking in general terms
oh yeah there's a chess grand master
and there's a guy who can't win at all
so clearly these things exist some
people are better than others
even if it's just one or two people who
are better at playing chess than most
other people than some people are
yeah but yeah that's that's that's how
michael defines separating the
you know yeah i'm a c-level chess player
and there's definitely better people
yeah dude that's that's that's crazy it
makes you right wing that's interesting
but what's interesting too is i think
there's a lot of people that are better
than me at like basically everything so
it's basically idealism versus realism
yeah yeah maybe yeah that's maybe that's
it that's basically what the you know
the conversation comes down to and
that's a problem there's no balance
available
well do you think that there should be
an element of government that is
better men and i i use men figuratively
i mean people
the best type of government is no
government yeah i should have should
have figured you'd say
yeah yeah yeah no government um
you got to let you got what about what
about like fire departments and police
departments
i like i like thinking about um when
iris created
the the first fire departments in boston
and in philadelphia
and originally they created fire
departments because they were actually
creating fires
that sounds like us and they were
fighting for so-called equality
so a lot of those things popped up
independently
and were funded independently
i think those are great community things
that can happen that don't need
government intervention
i think that there are people in this
world who
know their destiny know their know their
value
and will do a lot of things for free
there are some people who would
die to be a nurse and never take it they
could never take a scent and feel
some type of way they just enjoy doing
that people are just built like that
so i think things like you know fire
departments are easy to come by
isn't that idealistic though no that's
realistic
you know you know the shopping cart
problem you ever hear this one was that
so
they say the shopping cart corral is the
perfect test for whether or not humans
can self-govern
you go you go to the supermarket you get
a shopping cart you go to your car
you got the shopping cart next to your
car it takes almost no time to put the
shopping cart in the corral
but you don't get anything for it right
you know it's the right thing to do yeah
but still people will just leave their
shopping cart right there in the middle
of the lot just get in their car and
leave
and so the idea is you could do the
right thing for no reward that doesn't
really affect you at all
ten five ten seconds but people still
choose not to do it people in america
choose to do it
choose you may choose not to do it
choose not to do it right yeah yeah
you could pull another culture out and
you'd see something completely different
yes it's something to say about the
level of human consciousness in america
and the western world
the the the graduation of the ego
right it's very at a very low state at
this point so we have people
who who exist in this system you know
time is of the essence in america all
right and a lot of that has to do with
that 30 percent that gets taken out of
your check
regarding the fire department i feel
like it's kind of a specialized job you
got to train and learn how to do it
and carry the weight and all that you
know you know the whatever
what it takes to go into a building
fight the fire and uh takes time a lot
of time so if they weren't getting paid
they might not be able to to support
their lives um if it was a private
company
you'd look at like the roman fire
department's pompey's fire department
yeah the first
fire department that we know of and he
would go if the building was on fire
go outside with his fire department and
say pay me you need to extort the people
and the people be like
no i'm not going to pay you and then you
just let their building burn down yeah
the the original fire departments i
think used to buy an emblem
and you'd put the emblem on your house
okay and then when the fire call was was
called in they'd come and they'd see the
emblems okay
you're a subscriber you talk again
you're talking about
a level of low conscious human beings
right
you wouldn't have that in in in some
ancient societies you wouldn't have that
problem
you just have a fire department those
people will be taken care of
you know what you know it's interesting
i was reading uh they might get paid you
know
have we have we tried private fire
departments in
a local town and what that looks like
and is it possible
if we didn't have to pay 30 percent that
we'd pay maybe 10 percent to go to some
of those services and those would go
directly to those services i'm sorry
and those and those people might
actually get paid
what the government i think we should
build an
app where you get to pick where your
taxes go on a sliding bar and if you
wanted to slide like 17
to the fire department i want to slide
13 to the police department and you
might have minimums like you have to put
at least 20
into each then you get to pick and
you'll see like the voluntarism kick
in but why not why not how about then i
add i want the taxes to go to my
uh skate park so when you're you would
put your skate park
it'd be like tinder you'd be like hey
i'm simple i want to build a skate park
people go i like that i'm going to swipe
right and add that's my list of things
that i can fund yeah but then why not
i'll be like i'm going to give two
percent of my taxes to tim's skatepark
but then how about
we just take you know hotep's path and
say you can't get any of my 30
at all and just keep it all right yeah
so you should have that option too just
put in your pocket and if i want if i
want to go to a skate park i'll show up
your skateboard and give you money
yeah i think you know
man i'm not a big fan of government
authority i think a lot of it's
arbitrary
i've seen a lot of the arbitrary
authority put in action and a lot of
people
that play popularity contest to get the
keys to the castle to have that
authority yeah
but i still think you know i'm not an
anarchist i probably would be
i idealistically i'm like left
libertarian
and then realistically i'm like probably
just a liberal probably just like i
think we need
i think we need some kind of uh mixed
economy some kind of mix system
i think we should take all them terms
and throw them in the trash why is that
because listen to what you just said you
said when it comes to this i'm this when
it comes to that i'm okay but i can't
explain it
right but let's just talk about
each issue and and say what our views
are and not label it
all right right because then with those
labels come preconceived notions
i think one of the challenges is that
you look at the brooklyn bridge
so i'm not i'm not a historian on the
brooklyn bridge but my understanding is
that i was put together by a corporation
to build this bridge
right then you're trying to figure out
how to compensate everybody
and so you have this you know this
corporation originally my understanding
was supposed to dissolve after it was
done
yeah it comes you know yeah like toll
roads yeah yeah it exists
but then the bridge comes to exist
forever what do so what what do we do do
we
uh put up a toll for the bridge forever
i'm not saying it's a bad idea i'm
asking like a
serious question well allegedly the the
the fee that we paid through tolls was
supposed to be used to build a bridge
and
i believe there was a budget set aside
to maintain a bridge afterwards right
well for sure and then they saw how much
revenue was coming in and they said
why would we stop this money coming in
look at this but so
ignoring the well there you go that's
that's the first problem with government
corruption
yeah so why why kill the golden goose
we're gonna keep the money yeah so
what's the next part to it
so uh well i guess is the solution then
we keep the the bridge
under a private corporation and then
just have them
run it with their their interest only in
that you know bridge who built the
bridge
i think i think the brooklyn bridge was
built by like the brooklyn bridge
corporation or something like that
okay i could be wrong i could be wrong
it's like i was reading a plaque outside
of the brooklyn bridge or something
yeah so um i don't know it's a really
tough question
right the capitalist in me says the
corporation should own it
and they should be able to dictate who
can cross it and who can't and if you
don't like their rules don't go to
brooklyn
yeah that's what vanderbilt did with his
railroads but then when he wanted to
stop shipping food into new york he cut
them off and
starved a bunch of people that's usually
oh they also did that with coal and
everything yeah yeah and then and then
what happens is they nationalize it that
sounds
like exactly what happens you know but
then they also do things like make
growing hemp illegal
right yeah yup they make things like
collecting rainwater is illegal
well the collecting i wouldn't need your
shipment of food if you let me grow my
own
well the rain the rainwater thing in
some context makes sense
yeah because like if if uh uh in certain
areas like in suburban neighborhoods
there's rules about not collecting
rainwater having it runoff otherwise
you need a you need like a certain
amount of it's just like about
maintaining the the the environment for
everybody that are living really close
together
yeah but uh in a lot of places it makes
literally no sense so the bigger issue i
think is
rules that are made for cities that
affect people who don't live anywhere
near them
well well let me ask you this let's go
back to the railroad right who's going
to protect the railroad
um in general the police i think okay
please work for who federal
where local or federal all right so we
removed them who going to protect
vanderbilt from the people after he
started
he'd have to hire see what i'm saying
that's why
that's why government shouldn't be there
because what they do is these
corporations set up
and then they pay the government to
protect them protected yeah well
then they have the most elite security
force on the planet
that's why you get rid of government
check you know you know scenarios you
know what walmart does
right even better huh i don't know
walmart tells their employees
or there was there was i don't know if
this was a widespread thing but i
remember reading about how walmart told
their employees
if you can't afford to work here go on
go on food stamps
it's like you hired people and you're
telling them to get government benefits
to subsidize
their lives yeah that doesn't make sense
yeah i'm not i'm
not applying tell you you make too much
one more time
when you when you apply for some of
these uh right government assistance
they tell you you make too much
but it's kind of crazy to me that you
have these big corporations
where they're like we're going to hire
you we pay this much and if you can't
afford it
too bad go ask the government for
subsidies for a subsidy
if the government didn't provide that
they'd say doesn't exist you have to pay
more money
yeah so the fact that the government
offers it up actually allows these these
big
you know massive corporations to
undercut the the lower class the working
class
yeah yeah you wanna know something crazy
there's progressives that say they want
they want they want a lot of things they
want four day work week right
okay they want shorter shorter days they
want paid vacation
and they want it implemented through
policy and you know how the
some of these things started getting
implemented it wasn't policy it was
donald trump
the economy was booming and then all of
a sudden we started seeing a bunch of
companies say
we're going to reduce you know hours you
know same salary but now you only work
32.
we're going to give you paid vacation
because the economy was doing so well so
the fact that there was just a good
economy resulted in a lot of these
things that improved people's living
yeah i just feel like
you just let uh companies compete for
employees
and you know if this company is treating
their employees better than they compete
like that and say hey look you know i
heard that i heard they're giving four
days over here i want to apply for a job
there
right and then it changes the culture
you know the problem is that's what i'm
interested in
i think the problem is schools more oh
yeah more more more government i guess
is the problem
for sure yeah school is definitely maybe
the number one problem
along with i mean school and media are
kind of like one because
that's the brainwashing the
indoctrination unit
so you mentioned make p make the
businesses compete for employees right
but what happens when the people don't
understand any of these concepts and
just sit there saying why am i broke and
don't do anything about it
so i know i know a bunch of people that
go to school and they think the only way
to survive is to get a job
as if the employer is the supplier of
money is if the employer like
makes money appear out of thin air to
give to you you can make money too same
as them
yeah that's that's just one of those
things where you do as i say
i mean you know watch yeah how do you
say do as i do not as i said as i say
not as i do yeah
no no no actually that's not what rules
for thee but not for me no
watch just watch me do it yeah watch me
do it
and then people will emulate right
because you can talk to somebody and say
hey you should be an entrepreneur all
day
that don't mean they're going to be an
entrepreneur but when they see you do it
they go oh wait i think i can do that
leave by example
thank you lead by example that's that's
what i say i don't try to convince
people without being an entrepreneur
they just see how i'm living
and they're like yo how do you do that i
tell them and i said join my saturday
course
my saturday class or you know i'll
mentor you during the week but
you just got to be that example that's
the problem out here we're doing too
much talking
yeah not enough doing yeah not enough
doing hotep and build
you know i'm pretty concerned with
private military yeah i've talked about
state and the value of the state
yeah because tax isn't where they go
well that definitely that's crazy that
you don't know where your taxes are
going but up until like the 1400s there
was
all mercenary warfare pretty much okay
and it was one mercenary company would
go
burn down a village and then they'd get
hired by the people to go
defend the village that they you know
burned down yeah
so it's just a constant chaos and then
they they develop standing armies to
prevent mercenary
overtakes so we're basically in a world
of standing armies now that are funded
by
taxpayers yeah and i'm afraid that if we
go back to mercenaries
it would be corporate chaos no we we'd
just get the same thing we have now but
except you and i would be able to form a
militia
or become mercenaries but i don't want
to be in a militia right now
well that's useless right now though
there's people in arizona training right
now
i want people to protect me that's as
though that's who you want that's who
you want protecting well
i like specialization and yeah focus my
energy into creating
content you know thought stuff and then
have someone else carry the guns
have someone else grow in the crops yeah
you ever heard you ever heard a
statement about i'd rather be a
a warrior in a garden and a gardener in
the war
yeah yeah okay so i mean
my point is do you want the government
to have a monopoly on violence or not
because as it is the only people that's
allowed to
do this stuff are governments we
or rich people government rich people
because we're allowed to form standing
militias
as part of our own government yeah you
know you know that
private security they'll shove a cop for
you if you pay the right price
yes we've talked about this quite a bit
you can watch videos
where there's like some some dude is
like doing something the cops walk up to
them start yelling and then two
bodyguards shove the cops down
because those bodyguards are like these
guys have so much money they will buy
that police department out you will not
arrest me
absolutely these cops who get paid 30
40k
coming up and messing with a guy who's
worth hundreds of millions or billions
of dollars
and his private security gets they get
paid you know high six figures they're
going to be like
i don't care that's the life they're
going to take care of my family if i go
to jail
knock the cop down yeah that's great
that's how you got to live out here you
know
but i think there's a lot of people who
could be trained to be
armed security for the people you know
lady talk about like police
you got a kid in in high school who was
a bully well guess what
he's probably a natural guardian he's
probably a natural soldier
so let's put him in training and let's
make him guardian of the community a
bully though
a bully you gotta understand a bully has
sometimes some psychological issues
that maybe started as a as a youth
all he needs a little bit of therapy and
channel that energy into something good
a lot of times you have with disruptive
kids is
they're just not getting attention yeah
right and then
for example um there was this kid who
was bad in school
and what the teacher used to do was she
used to make him the volunteer
and all of a sudden the bad behavior
disappeared but it's because all the
other teachers would ignore him
wouldn't let him volunteer wouldn't let
him get up be the one and sharpen the
pencils or pass out the papers but she
made him a little helper
and now he's an a student yeah it's
about understanding human psychology and
people don't want to tackle that you
know what i think your response what
you're saying ian
i think you underestimate your ability
you you should be responsible for you
should be a well-rounded person every
capacity you should you should be able
to defend yourself protect yourself
you should be able to be the one who
carries the gun and you can focus on the
things you're more passionate about
but i think you know you wake up you
read you exercise
you make sure you're you're well-rounded
with your specialties
you can be a specialist in content
creation doesn't mean you shouldn't be
able to
you know carry heavy things or you don't
farm no i don't
no of course not you're specialized sort
of
but i could farm i could farm too but
you don't and i don't because we're
specialized and that's because this
sociological construct of the government
allows us to be specialized but i
actually like farming well i like to do
a lot of stuff i don't do but you should
do hydroponics
yeah we had a garden at the last house
you should just set up like well that
was mostly
yeah you got to you got the skate part
popping up right yeah skateboarding yeah
so you need another building with just
the hydroponics man that's the future
we were thinking about doing that with
the with the detached building we have
but
it's all it's there's no light so we
have to like figure out a way to do
something
with like a greenhouse i guess yeah
greenhouse that bad bloom
but dude dude first of all like i am all
about
self-sufficiency you know what i mean
like we're we're almost off the grid at
this point if you try and do everything
you'll end up coming up short and i
disagree with things
there's there's there's two specialized
there's two sayings
it's an ancient japanese saying a person
who tries to catch two rabbits will
catch neither
right and then there's another saying
that you may have heard jack of all
trades master of yeah right
jack of all trades master uh jack of all
trades master of none but every so often
better than a master of one
that's a full saying so it's it's
you know it depends you know in in a
culture of
all specialists yeah you know that's
what we've become
and we're hyper specialized now it's
like when it comes to building a
computer you've got
like actually components and parts
you've got some people who specialize in
one tiny aspect of like
building the computer right someone
focuses on like developing the plastics
for the casings or whatever
right it used to be like way back in the
day the blacksmith was the guy who would
like
make the thing right now you've got
added you know thousand different
specialties to get that job done
that's actually allowed us to make crazy
new technology and improve things and
but i think there's still fundamentals
that everybody should probably work on
being fit for instance knowing how to
use a gun probably
i think these are important things
there's like basic necessities for life
that's basic necessities for it man it's
like knowing how to change a tire
yeah yep just like simple things simple
um and dependent depending on how good
you want to be at them you know
but i think you know what i tell people
i tell people the one thing you can do
right now is download a survival guide
onto your phone
you might not never need to use it yeah
but yeah but then you
absolutely that's a good idea how many
how many how many stories we heard about
someone went for a walk and then they
got lost in the woods right
so you look pull up your phone and it'll
say oh here's what i do okay cool
i got a wilderness survival merit badge
and boy scouts i'm good out here
there you go man i'm not like
a sycophant for the government for
government daddy to take care of us but
i value some of the the safety that it
provides i guess for the freedom
yeah the freedom like what like um if i
go outside and someone wants to
mug me they'll do that well not if
there's a police officer standing by
that's i don't know how what are the
odds of that and and people get directed
you ever seen andy no get beat up in
front of police oh no not in front of
police i didn't see that
dude you see the video of the trump
supporters the maga family
yeah they're trying to leave and the
cops stopped them and made them
go into antifa yeah so look i
like i said i think we need police i
think police serve a function
i'm not an anarchist or anything like
that but i absolutely have no problem
criticizing the cops
we've had way too much this year of cops
just enforcing these unconstitutional
edicts from governors
yeah instead of actually being there to
help the people and protect them
we had these gym owners by the old house
in jersey where they they got arrested
yeah for just working out in a building
yeah these cops didn't care i'm free to
drive
on the freeway without getting hit by
speeding cars because you want the car
speeding
no they say that people tend to
concentrate
more when they speed oh they sure do but
if people are going different speeds
did you realize that most accidents are
happening like within five minutes of
your house
i've heard that yeah and and like
usually like
not speeding yeah but that's because
people aren't going 30 miles an hour
differentials on the freeway because we
have speed limits
usually usually people don't crash
because people are speeding
so
[Music]
and then under penalty of law no i mean
the people always speed
they always be and then everybody's
dangerous everybody goes five
seven miles an hour over maybe i think
that's my person and then what happens
is
i've done 130 before it's so delicious
i've done 130
in a honda accord
it's not a piece of metal the car the
car isn't even metal
is
he taught me how to drive but you know i
took that that bad boy down 280
doing 130 when i was like 18 years old
but your concentration your focus is
spiked not i
don't suggest doing that and keep in
mind um but i know how to drive really
well you need a driver you highlight me
i'm real good at driving my brother's
actually a race car driver
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you